만약에 이쪽 지역의 건물을 가지고
계시거나 아니면 이쪽 지역에
투자하시는 분
계신다면이 지금 내용들을 좀 잘
지켜보신 필요가 있을 것 같습니다
[음악]
그 사람입니다 제가 오늘은
토지거래허가구요에 대해서
이야기를 좀 나눠 보려고 합니다
토지거래허가구역이
삼성 대치
청담
잠실이 최근에 연장이 됐습니다
기존의 살고 계셨던 분들이 반발이
되게 컸어요
근데 아무래도 이번에 좀 그 서울시가
연장을 했는데 그 이후에 좀 이렇게
기사나
얘기들이 나오는 거를 여러분들한테 좀
알려드리려고
영상을 찍게 됐습니다 일단 기사를
보면은 10월 달에 이제 부동산
거래신고
등
법률이 좀 바뀌어요 그래서 그때 바꿀
때 상가나
업무시설은 빼겠다 뭐 이런 얘기들이
좀 많이 나오고 있어요
처음에 이제이 토지거래허가구역이
생겼을 때
원래 대부분 이제 주택 가격을 좀
이렇게 안정화시키려고 한 정책인데
상업용이나 이제 업무용도 같이
묶었거든요 그래서 처음에 이제 묶였을
때 공무원분들도 되게 혼란이 좀
많았어요 저희가 전화해서 물어보면
일단 잘 모르고 그리고
처음에 이제 허가 해줄 때는 건물을
멸실하면 사용을 안 해도 된다 뭐
이렇게 해서 허가 받으신 분들은 또
계시고 아니면 반 정도는 사용을 해야
된다 뭐 이렇게 해서 허가 받으신
분도 계시고 아니면 그냥
층에 일부분만 써도 되니까
허가 해주겠다 해서 이렇게 허가
받으신 분도 계시고 근데 최근에서야
이렇게 한계층을 써야지 허가를
해준다는 내용을 좀 정리되긴 했는데
정말 좀 되게 혼란스러웠어요 저도
이제 실무하는 입장에서
강남구랑
송파구랑 또 얘기가 또 다른 경우도
있고 그리고 그때그때 이제 전화 받는
분들 따라 또 얘기가 또 다르고 정말
난리도 아니었습니다
난리도 아니었고 저는
이번에 좀 토지 거래 허가구역이
풀리면
기존에 좀 반사이 갔던 때가
신사
노년 역삼에 좀 거래가 많이 됐었어요
근데 이번에 만약에 풀리게 되면
청담 대치 삼성
잠실 이쪽이 상업용
업무용 이런 빌딩들 거래량이 좀 많이
살아날 것으로 예상이 됩니다 그래서
저 개인적으로는 지금
이제서라도 좀 이런 내용이 나와서
정말 너무 다행이고이 토지거래허가구역
때문에
매각을 못 하신 분들이 되게 많거든요
건물을
지었는데 이것도 이제 일정부분
사용해야 되고 일정 기간 동안
매각을 못 한다고 하니까 좀
자금적으로 문제가 생기신 분들도 많고
합니다 이번에 만약에 이제 상업용이나
업무용이 풀리게 되면은 이런 분들이
좀
숨통이 트릴 것 같아요 좀 혜택도
받으실 것 같고 어떻게 보면 좀
진작에 풀렸어야 되는데 어떻게
보면은이 상업용이나
업무용은 좀 풀렸어야 되는데 이번에
좀 풀린 거를
정말 저는 좀 다행이라고 생각합니다
좀 10월까지 지켜봐야 될 거 같긴
한데 어찌됐든 지금 좀 여론이나 좀
이런 서울시에서 얘기하는 거 들어보면
상업용이나 업무용은 재래될 가능성이
크기 때문에 만약에 이쪽 지역의
건물을 가지고 계시거나 아니면 이쪽
지역에 투자하시는 분
계신다면이 지금 내용들을 좀 잘
지켜보신 필요가 있을 것 같습니다
그래서 그 토지거래허가구역 자체가
이제 주택을 규제하고자 해 가지고
만들어진 거고 그 특히 갭 투자를 좀
방지하려고 만든 법이거든요 기존에
원래 주택을 한 채만 가지고 있어야
되는데
갭투자로 되게 여러 채를 사면서 그런
투기 수요를 막겠다고 해가지고
토지거래허가구역을 만든 건데 여기에
이제 상업용이 같이 들어간 거예요
어떻게 보면 좀 불합리한 경우가 되게
많았는데 이번에
풀리면은
그렇게 피해 봤던 분들이 다행이지
않을까 싶습니다 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 토지거래허가구역
내용이 세부적으로 좀 어떻게 바뀌는지
여러분들도
관심있게 지켜보시면 좋을 것 같습니다
오늘 영상 여기까지 하겠습니다
감사합니다